Eevee's electric vehicles you have the
bolt evey coming out sometime toward the
end of this year who is the target
audience who are you really directing
that car for well I think with a 200
mile range you really have addressed
range anxiety for most people and so
when you look at the fact that we're
putting a vehicle out that is gonna get
more than 200 miles range at an
affordable price of 30 thousand dollars
after incentives I think it opens up for
a lot of people who can look at their
use case and say not only is this a car
that I can drive you know to and from
work but for my my use case my lifestyle
this is a vehicle that's going to meet
my needs and be my only vehicle and
we're really excited about that and
we're exciting to be first into the
marketplace with an affordable
evie with 200 mile range well first in
the marketplace there are other vehicles
out there that at least think that
they'll be competing with a bolt they
may be wrong but they think and we can
name them you know things like Nissan
Leaf and Prius and things like that is
your car really unique is there a moat
around this car in that sense well I
think when you're looking at hybrids I
mean we have the Volt that has done well
and we're you know seeing great
reception to the second generation of
the vote where we've learned a lot and
listen to the Volt customers to make the
next generation even better but what
makes the bull TV stand aside is it's
all electric and 200 miles range and
that and it's affordable and that's what
distinguishes it and yes we are unique
in the marketplace and offering that to
the customer there's another company out
there that starts with a team fit it is
says it's coming out with an
all-electric vehicle in a year's time
they say more or less Tesla with the
series 3 - look at it now I drove a bulb
your people were nice enough to let me
drive a world and it is a very exciting
car I'm an amazing torque very practice
ting car it's a wonderful car in my
experience Australian but when you look
at it's a very different car from a
series 3 they don't look the same at all
why did you target the bolt evey the way
you did which seem to be more
utilitarian more family 5 seating
capacity why did you pick that market to
go for well I think when you look at how
you generate in the and provide an
electric vehicle for for everyone which
we're doing with the Chevrolet
Boal TV they need the utility the
utility of you know being able to
comfortably seat five people and have a
you know a spacious rear I mean when you
look at the vehicle I hope one of the
things you notice is inside it's like
it's a big car and so we've been able to
package and create and really as a B car
segment a si car interior that provides
the space and room that people need as
part of their everyday lives and so
that's why we went and said let's make
this more SUV light because we think
that's gonna provide the most value for
a person again that it might be their
only vehicle why does the investors at
least like Tesla so much well I think
it's one of the reasons we're really
working to lead an autonomous and and
make sure people understand connectivity
and and products like the ball TV
because it's about the future it's where
are you going and how are you going to
create value and you know we are working
hard to make sure we are gonna create
substantial shareholder value you asked
earlier about how we make capital
decisions we I spent an incredible
amount of time on how we deploy capital
making sure we're doing that in the best
interest of our investors but and we
have a core business that allows that
allows us to fund that and as people see
yes General Motors is a tech company
that is leading with a multitude of
technologies I think the story will
change so I look at it as what we need
to do to prove our the value that we're
creating and that's where I stay focused
is it realistic for General Motors to
trade if not at the multiple of Tesla no
one does hardly but to really increase
your multiple as people become used to
the idea that you are a tech company as
you say with autonomous driving and v's
I absolutely think and we think are sure
we think we're undervalued right now and
we're gonna continue to work to keep
making sure people understand exactly
the mission of General Motors and what
we're working toward how we're investing
and and the capabilities and the
strengths we have and again I I believe
and come to work every day that is we
continue to do that that's something
that will will take care of itself